now imagine a line where you set up an
opening trap which is going to occur in
the middle game and it is such a
powerful that you sacrifice your two
Bishops and the position get a
completely checkmate
sounds very interesting right
welcome guys as in this video you are
going to witness
world's one of the longest and deadliest
chest strap which specially in online
chess occurs frequently
[Music]
thank you
after D4 Knight to F6 C4
we have the move E5 known as Budapest
defense
and when do I take this Pawn the
majority of the games continue with
Knight to G4
which goes into the Budapest Gambit
territory however there is another
killer alternative here namely Knight to
E4 and this is known as
fajarowicz Gambit which is currently my
secret weapon for the online chairs
here white can fall into the Trap via
two ways so they can choose either the
move A3 or Knight to F3 let's say in
this game white plays Knight to F3 first
and after this I recommend this very
sneaky move D6
putting the pressure on the E5 pawn and
somewhere down the line we want to grab
it by developing our pieces
okay if you look at the database here by
far the most popular choice is e
captures D6
whereupon black regain the pawn with
Bishop captures D6
and yup at this point white is a pawn up
but black is steaming ahead in terms of
Peace development
and again white can choose either of the
moves such as E3 or Knight B to D2
doesn't matter both of them leads to the
same trappy territory for example E3
so white is planning to Castle on the
king side
and on the counterpart after Knight to
C6
black shows his intention as he really
want to Castle on the queen side
so we have some natural moves Bishop to
E2
Bishop to fi Castle on the king side and
now Queen to E7 get ready to Castle
after Knight B to D2 as white wants to
get rid of the centralized Knight
we can Castle on the queen side
and there is a small trap within the
Trap hearings if your opponent continue
with Knight captures E4 then this is the
last time he is going to play it as
after Bishop takes H2 white to his
horror find out that he has lost his
Queen
so nope that's not the point as soon as
the Rook comes on the D file it is very
obvious that majority of the games
continue with Queen 24 getting out of
the attack and putting the pressure on
that seven pound
whereupon we can start delivering the
king side attack
with this nice move G5
okay so black is threatening the Muji
for and accordingly the most frequent
Choice from the white side is to First
Take This Knight and after Bishop takes
there is no point of playing H3 as H5
and G4 is on the card
so white should start attack on the
black king with either the move A3 or B4
and in both the case let's say E3 we can
play G4
and if the Knight moves which happen in
almost all the games
then congratulations to the wide as he
has fallen into world's most deadliest
and longest trap
so before I move on guys I'd like you to
pause this video and find out a killer
sequence here which finish up the word
from this position
are you ready
I think I already given you the hint
right
and congratulations if you find the
first move yup absolutely right Bishop
takes us to bang
the point is after King takes you give
this check and when white plays the move
King to G1
he get another root shock
yup you got it
Bishop captures G2
another dazzling Bishop sacrifice
so that white cannot denied it as we are
threatening the move Queen H1 Checkmate
so white has to take it and after this
the sequence is very easy you keep this
check
King to jivan and yet another forcing
Checkmate move G3
whereupon white has tried two moves but
neither of them are walking
first the easiest move is if we continue
with f captures G3 then after Queen
captures G3 King to H1 and now the star
move Rook to G8
finished the job as black is threatening
multiple Checkmate and unfortunately
white cannot defend all of them
okay then what about the second option
Knight to F3 here
well more or less seems to be we play
Rook to G8 threatening g capital F2
and after something like Rook to D1
trying to give some space to the white
king doesn't work here as after the
forcing sequence black indeed achieved
the checkmate
you wanna try it go ahead buddy I'm
showing you right now
Pawn takes F2 Jack King takes
Rook to G2 check
ing to even and now very simple Queen G3
King F1 and queen F2
a picturesque checkmate at just 20
second move of the game
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn world's most longest and deadliest
trap
and I must say this two Bishop sacrifice
line gives you lot of chills and great
victories as I have get 20 plus victims
in my online chess including two title
players
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care